[Music]
in mega flop new flower megaflops
submitted by [ __ ] was that oh you're
gonna fight dude I'm just cracking
mutter to crack it was like it was it
was it was how you grab your arm
you never done oh oh no I could only
crack my back
let's get by the end of it I might be
able to do it again [ __ ] my knuckles
like that hi I just I've been this way
and then like these these are kind of
crack I can't crack that no your elbows
crack - yeah oh you're weird I guess so
you're weird I know
grab my shoulder it's make me
self-conscious I can crack my shoulders
like this sometimes I'm done your
shoulders yeah I want to go out when I
go straight up my bone hero and I go
straight like this and then I go like
see like this sometimes not but
sometimes it goes down and you could
crack my breath yeah I could do that
well there you go
are you Bruce Lee crap oh whoa keep
going oh no that's me a thumbs it's
mighty hard you tricked me man I'll
crack my neck sometimes
[Laughter]
hey that's like a grandma's ass
submitted by Mara ding-dong ding-dong
the most expensive Chinese film ever was
pulled from theaters after it bombed and
its opening week oh god jack ma field
yeah is it dyma is this skyscraper not
there well in China
this one's way more expensive over with
the rock 100 million dollars cost 100
million make 200 supposed to be China's
Lord of the Rings starring Matt Damon
like I guess I'm super sci-fi heading
its Lord of the Ling's we finally found
you
[Music]
that Jay Chou know such a lot of famous
Chinese
Oh Fiji so bad the realm of desire oh my
god for real that was us Lord of the
Rings in Avatar who you are he's in it
welcome home
maybe this means I have to die
you won't die you will be reborn to be
even in the world will be destroyed
it looks cool it looks epic as [ __ ]
surah Asuka they spent a lot of movie
money on this movie and people just
hated it
it looks [ __ ] epic it looked really
cool yeah they're saying that it took
six years to me oh my god they pulled it
up to how long the opening week what it
was that bad why wouldn't even just give
it time in a [ __ ] marinade you lose
money by it being in theaters it does
cost money to get the distribution and
be in theaters oh I see maybe they
thought they were losing more money
having it like paying theater that must
have been reading I want to watch him
there was no high built behind it yeah
there was a lot but people just didn't
show up
well apparently it was the ratings that
were so bad they it got a three point
one out of ten Wow Oh like critics
critics yet wow there's Chinese critics
yeah film industry is huge they're
second in the world I just didn't know
people did the same [ __ ] like I didn't
know they have opinions and [ __ ] and
then you know what the Chinese food or a
vegetable like a popular one tomatoes
yeah pepper and then have way bigger I
was like is tomato a fruit or vegetable
it's a fruit or vegetables I'd say as to
a Chinese food event you think about the
same light Qi rotten light chilli cheese
it can't be read a copy read till what
else is read y'all don't have any red
vegetables fruits I don't run an
eggplant why's it gotta be red though
yeah tomato I don't know
anyway anyways see that's what happens
when a joke goes bad usually doesn't
leave your head when you think too hard
it comes out and you see how it [ __ ] up
you're right Brandon they are saying
that by 2020 they're expected to surpass
the US and Canada is the biggest
theatrical market American Hollywood
films are they're producing films
fortune for China - Chinese audience
thanks about Megalodon oh the mag yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that one's
completely produced by China really if
it seems like the rock doesn't really
care about the audience here yeah it
seems like he's trying to get after the
China market cuz that's where the real
money yeah that's where the money's at
now don't quote me on this cuz I don't
know a hundred percent you might do the
research but I saw the numbers for
skyscraper and it was like 30 mil and
out of that 30 mil five was the US or
some [ __ ] it was like a very small
fraction of it I'm crazy so I was like
mind blowing like what the [ __ ] why
skyscraper so poppin in China American
movies that do well in China are the
ones that don't take too much cultural
understanding again so like easy movies
that like action movies you know
disaster movie
right I'm so much relatability to it you
know so because all those other ones do
really well like the [ __ ] natural
design like [ __ ] well you could
literally not even know what they're
saying you know what's going on yes yeah
yeah yeah because what's happening is I
think a lot of people in Hollywood now
are just going out and writing for them
- for that yeah their film industry Wow
they don't understand the structure and
the theory behind it yes so they can't
create their own films aside from their
kung-fu dramas and stuff and and their
whatever they usually do mmm so you're
saying people are writing scripts in
English translating to China and getting
mention made out there yeah yeah yeah it
was marked a huge market man I mean but
if you think about it what is it a
billion people yeah they have a [ __ ] ton
of people true we have 300 million so
even if US combined with Canada and
Australia and all the English company
countries got together we still can't
make up the same amount of people that's
in China and it's probably so crowded
it's like why even go out and you just
stay inside so everyone's just like you
know go to the movies and [ __ ] we're
watching Netflix or what isn't it the
epics out there no they have checks
checks which she clicks chick flicks
yeah
they're saying that this movie was just
so bad that the writing was horrible and
like they couldn't distract the viewer
enough with all the pretty cgi so that's
the Chinese Michael Bay right there was
AI basic structure Chinese um was
happily the blonde girl special hats
were Scarlett Johansson right now zero
blonde girl special effects were super
dobos based in a mental hospital but
they were dreaming and was like it was
like mad anyways it was really bad oh I
know what you're talking about
yeah Jamie Jamie Jamie Chung was in it
yeah it was like a bunch of badass girls
that like [ __ ] it pick some ass it
looked amazing like the special effects
looked [ __ ] dope but I was watching
it and I was like I don't I don't walk
out of a lot of movies and I didn't walk
out of this one with all time I was like
oh my god this is horrible like I would
have yeah look out what is calling I was
trying to be like a Sin City but it was
like yeah I wonder if China would like
Chinese American content because they
could relate kind of right or whatever
or or they could relate to the
chineseness and then it's like a bridge
yeah but they still get their American
action and I hope so that'd be perfect
for me but I don't know I don't know if
they would actually I think they will
eventually I think is dope that they're
actually criticizing a film I feel like
if they like skyscraper and all those
movies that we we think is terrible it's
like they they have a very basic
knowledge of filmmaking but them
criticizing this one yeah the most
expensive one in their country and you
know Chinese before watch it's like
actually hella good is that they're so
dumb they didn't understand yeah yeah I
don't watch it now a lot of the
producers of the movie are saying that
it's organized trolling that is
responsible for all of the negative
reaction really so what they think
there's like some vendetta out against
the movie or what Russians aggressive
attack by water army water army
yeah so there are aiming to artificially
inflate poor ratings so are the ratings
from like viewers or from critics does
it say
because I know like sometimes they need
their own Rotten Tomatoes people that
make movies get mad at Rotten Tomatoes
sometimes because it's so influential
right yeah Ryan tomatoes you'll see all
these like the shitty reviews and then
it'll really mess up box office sales
sometimes because of that but sometimes
I like to go ride Tomatoes and look at
movies that I liked and I'll see their
like bad ratings that sounds like y'all
I'm never listening to this [ __ ] again
because people you know your tastes are
so different yeah I don't watch trailers
or read anymore right I stopped doing
that because I recently watched a game
night okay I don't know anything about
it I just walked in all so long as a
comedy let's just check it out I [ __ ]
love that experience of just walking in
and then like just give it to me
mm-hmm come on give it no expectations
yeah in the trailer - yeah I just I try
to avoid trailers to get in cuz
sometimes all the best [ __ ] seeds are
in the trailer oh yeah I had the
experience with that this is the end
you'll remember this at the end yeah yes
so I went in and she watched it thinking
who's just gonna be a Seth Rogen like
people talking funny dirty [ __ ] movie
right and then we call this [ __ ] started
happening like the blue lights on the
sky were like what but we loved it
that's how the points was the name of
the movie I googled that sound like
chicken cartilage
[Music]